Es muss unser Ziel sein, jede Infektionskette verfolgen zu können.
Dafür arbeiten wir auch an einer App.
Und die Idee ist, dass eine App dabei helfen kann, das deutlich schneller und effizienter zu machen.
Mobilphone Apps, die jetzt derzeit programmiert werden, die ich für extrem wichtig halte.
Die Tracing App kann sicher eine wichtige Rolle spielen.
Corona App.
Mit dieser Tracing App.
Wo ist denn die vielversprechende Corona App?
Die Frage der App.
Das ist einer der wichtigsten Schlüssel auf dem Weg in einen neuen Alltag.
Für viele ist sie die große Hoffnung auf ein Ende des Lockdowns.
Die Tracing-App.
Für Bund und Länder ist eine App gegen Corona schon lange eine „zentral wichtige Maßnahme“.
Also einfach App aufs Handy, dann werden wir gewarnt, wenn wir Kontakt mit Infizierten hatten
und wir können alle wieder raus und zurück ins normale Leben.
Klingt doch super. So einfach ist es aber nicht.
In diesem Video erkläre ich euch, was die App bringen soll,
was sie aktuell schon kann, beziehungsweise, wie sie funktioniert.
Und wir schauen am Ende darauf, warum sie uns vermutlich nicht aus dem Lockdown retten wird.
Weil ich keine IT-Expertin bin und auch keine Ahnung von Kryptographie habe,
habe ich mit Linus Neumann, einem Sprecher des „Chaos Computer Clubs“ über die wichtigsten Fragen gesprochen.
„Es gibt eine ganze Menge Heilsversprechen, die aktuell mit so einer App verbunden werden.
Und es ist wichtig, zu verstehen, wo auch die natürlichen Grenzen dieses Ansatzes sind.
Und vor allem erst mal zu verstehen: Was soll diese App überhaupt machen?“
Wir alle wollen, dass es aufhört.
Wir wollen raus aus dem Lockdown.
Wir wollen Freunde wiedersehen, wir wollen wieder zur Arbeit, zur Familie und so weiter.
Aktuell ist es so, dass wir zuhause bleiben müssen, weil wir die Kontrolle darüber verloren haben, wer wo wen angesteckt hat.
Wir sind aktuell nicht mehr in der Lage, die Infektionsketten genau nachzuvollziehen.
Das liegt unter andrem daran, dass man 14 Tage lang ansteckend ist
und, dass 45% der Ansteckungen passieren, bevor man überhaupt Symptome hat.
Das heißt: Man merkt selber noch überhaupt nicht, dass man krank ist, steckt aber in der Zeit schon Menschen an.
Unsere Gesundheitsämter, die eigentlich dafür da sind, genau diesen Job zu machen und die Infektionsketten nachzuvollziehen,
sind aktuell zum einen überlastet, zum anderen dauert die Methode, mit der das aktuell erfasst wird,
nämlich in solchen Tabellen, relativ lang.
Das Ziel einer Tracing App ist es also, die Infektionsketten schneller zu erfassen und dadurch schneller zu unterbrechen.
Also zu verhindern, dass sich noch mehr Menschen anstecken.
Wie und ob eine App das leisten kann, dazu gibt es ganz unterschiedliche Einschätzungen.
Eine Studie aus Oxford legt jetzt nah, dass eine App helfen könnte, aber wie genau soll das gehen?
Bei den sogenannten Tracing Apps geht es nicht um GPS- oder Bewegungsdaten, sondern darum, mit wem man Kontakt hatte.
Wenn sich also zwei Handys, auf denen die App installiert ist, länger als 15 Minuten und einem geringeren Abstand als 2 Metern treffen,
dann tauschen sie gegenseitig ihre ID's aus
und diese werden dann verschlüsselt und anonymisiert auf den Handys gespeichert.
Ganz wichtig ist dabei, das passiert ohne Ortsmarken und ohne irgendwelche Informationen über die Person, die wir da getroffen haben.
Es werden wirklich nur die pseudonymisiert ID's gespeichert.
Wenn man dann positiv auf Corona getestet wird, meldet man das in der App.
Diese Meldung muss von einem Arzt oder einer Ärztin bestätigt werden, um zu verhindern, dass Missbrauch geschieht.
Und dann bekommt jede Person, mit der man in einem bestimmten Zeitraum Kontakt hatte, eine Pushnachricht auf das Handy, die sagt:
„Du hattest Kontakt mit einer Person, die mit Corona infiziert ist.“
Dann kann sich jeder in Isolation begeben und so wird die Kontaktkette und die Weitergabe der Infektion unterbrochen.
„Das heißt, wir würden so eine App nutzen, um die Kontakte unserer Kontakte zu schützen.
Und zwar genau die Kontakte, die unsere Kontakte nicht haben, weil sie die Warnung durch die App bekommen haben.“
Für die Tracing-App gab es lange unterschiedliche Ansätze und auch mehrere Diskussionen um Datenschutz.
Denn es geht natürlich um hochsensible Daten, um Gesundheit und darum, mit wem man Kontakt hatte.
Die Frage, die am Ende immer wieder im Raum stand, war die,
ob die Daten zentral, also auf einem Server, beispielsweise des RKI's,
oder dezentral, also auf jedem einzelnen Handy abgeglichen werden sollen.
Die Bundesregierung war für die zentrale Variante. Das heißt:
Sie wollten, dass alle Daten auf einem Server zusammenfließen.
Dagegen gab es massive Kritik.
Dagegen gab es Mahnungen und offene Briefe. Unter anderem von Linus Neumann und dem „Chaos Computer Club“.
Die haben geschrieben: Ein Scheitern wäre unausweichlich.
Und in diese ganze Diskussion kam dann die Meldung, dass Apple und Google zusammenarbeiten wollen.
Was Corona nicht alles möglich macht.
Und die beiden Tech-Giganten wollen eine Schnittstelle anbieten, auf der die Apps dann aufbauen können.
Die Situation hat sich am Ende darauf zugespitzt, dass die Bundesregierung einen zentralisierten Ansatz bevorzugen würde
und Apple und Google nur einen dezentralen Ansatz ermöglichen würden.
Apple und Google, große Konzerne, die die Macht über diese Geräte haben und die sagen können:
Das funktioniert mit dem Gerät und das nicht.
Und grundsätzlich der Ansatz einer „Bluetooth Beacon“-basierten Corona App, würde auf einem Iphone ohnehin nicht funktionieren,
wenn Apple nicht Zugeständnisse macht.
Also kam es zu einer 180-Grad Wende im Gesundheitsministerium:
Aus zentral wurde dezentral und so soll die App jetzt kommen.
Gleichzeitig hat die Bundesregierung die Gründe, die sie zum zentralen Ansatz geführt haben, nicht aufgegeben.
Und zwar sind das zwei Wünsche:
A) Ein Lernen dieser App zu ermöglichen durch Feedback.
Wenn Sie in der ersten Woche eine Entscheidung getroffen hat, in der zweiten Woche eine Validierung bekommt, zum Beispiel über Testung der Person.
Hat sich der Verdacht erhärtet, dass die Person einem Risiko ausgesetzt war, oder nicht?
Dass durch dieses Feedback die Entscheidungsqualität der App natürlich gesteigert werden kann.
Ganz klassisches Maschine Learning.
Und das zweite Ziel, was die Bundesregierung verfolgt, ist natürlich besserer Aufklärung über den Verlauf der Pandemie zu bekommen.
Im zentralisierten Ansatz werden diese beiden Ziele sehr teuer erkauft.
Nämlich mit einem zentralisierten Monitoring der Bürgerinnen und Bürger.
Im dezentralen Ansatz ist es möglich zu sagen: Ok , gebt uns doch diese Daten, wenn ihr möchtet freiwillig.
Wenn ihr nicht möchtet, ist auch in Ordnung. Bekommt ihr trotzdem die App.
Der Teufel steckt auch hier im Detail und noch ist nicht ausgeschlossen, dass es zu weiteren Datenschutzproblemen kommt,
aber so, wie die App gerade geplant ist, ist sie keine Datenkrake.
Dafür, dass die App, wenn sie dann mal da ist, überhaupt etwas bringt, gibt es einiges an Voraussetzungen.
Damit die App wirklich einen Einfluss auf die Infektionsketten haben kann, müssen wirklich viele Menschen diese App nutzen.
Expertinnen und Experten rechnen damit, dass ungefähr 60% der Bevölkerung die App nutzen müssen und auch immer anhaben
und auch das Handy immer bei sich haben müssen.
60%. Das sind ungefähr alle Smartphonebesitzer in Deutschland.
Aber: Nicht mehr jedes Gerät, jedes Smartphone in Deutschland ist überhaupt aktuell in der Lage, das Bluetooth Low Energy zu nutzen
und manche wollen sich die App vielleicht auch einfach nicht installieren.
Laut aktuellem ZDF-Politbarometer wären 47% bereit, die App nutzen. Das sind aber immer noch zu wenige.
Und das ist ein zentrales Problem.
Bislang steht aber ganz klar fest und das wurde von mehreren Politikerinnen und Politikern an ganz vielen Stellen betont:
Die App soll freiwillig sein.
Das heißt: Niemand wird dazu gezwungen, sich die App herunterzuladen und deshalb braucht es vor allen Dingen eins:
Vertrauen in diese App.
Wie steht es um dich?
Zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt gibt es die App noch nicht.
Ich werde natürlich der App unter die Haube schauen, ich werde sie mir genau anschauen
und werde dann meine Entscheidung treffen.
Aber die zentrale Richtungsentscheidung war jetzt schon die Richtige.
Es ist auf jeden Fall jetzt noch viel schwieriger noch Fehler zu machen,
die mich am Ende davon abhalten würden, diese App zu nutzen.
Stand jetzt erwartet uns datenschutzmäßig keine Katastrophe.
Dezentrales Tracing ist selbst für Experten die beste Möglichkeit.
Selbst, wenn wir das alles hinbekommen und eine App auf den Markt kommt, der man datenschutzrechtlich trauen kann,
die sich so viel Menschen herunterladen, wie notwendig, bleibt trotzdem die Frage:
„Was kann so eine App überhaupt leisten?“
Auch diese Frage hat unendlich viele Facetten.
Eine entscheidende ist aber die, wie stabil und wie zuverlässig ist überhaupt die Technik, die dem Ganzen zugrunde liegt,
nämlich die Bluetooth-Übertragung.
Dieses Verfahren wurde noch nie dazu eingesetzt und ist urspünglich auch nicht dafür gemacht, Abstände genau zu messen.
Und um zu unterscheiden: Befindet sich jetzt eine Glaswand zwischen Person A und B
und wie weit sind sie wirklich voneinander entfernt?
Also wie stark sind die Signalstärken, wo ist das Handy, wie herum halte ich es?
Alles Auswirkungen. Und dem entsprechend kann es auch Auswirkungen auf die Messgenauigkeit haben.
Expertinnen und Experten für künstliche Intelligenz sind jetzt relativ optimistisch,
dass man dies der App antrainieren kann. Das heißt, dass sie lernen kann, die Abstände relativ genau einzuschätzen.
Expertinnen und Experten für Funktechnologie sind skeptischer ...
Es ist ganz sicher so, dass wie jedes Messverfahren – insbesondere hier eins dass es noch nie gab
und was in kurzer Zeit für große Teile der Bevölkerung ausgerollt werden soll, das hier Ungenauigkeiten bleiben werden.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass wir hier mit einer gestützten Erfassung leben werden, wo die App vielleicht nachfragt:
„Hast du hier gerade einen Kontakt? Kannst du mal kurz verifizieren?“
Oder, dass wir am Ende nicht so genaue Daten bekommen, sondern, dass uns bei der Gedächtnisstütze geholfen wird.
So etwas wie:
„Hier am Mittwoch zwischen 17 und 18 Uhr.
Evaluier‘ mal, ob du da wirklich die ganze Zeit eine Gesichtsmaske auf hattest.“
Auch das ist ja etwas, das die App nicht erfassen kann.
Das heißt: Fehlalarme können also nicht ausgeschlossen werden.
Da kann eine falsch getunte App dafür sorgen, dass zu viele Leute False Allerts kriegen und das ganze Projekt ist erledigt.
Denn nach dem dritten oder fünften Mal, bei dem man unnötig fälschlicher Weise benachrichtigt wurde,
nimmt man das Ganze wahrscheinlich weniger ernst.
Dieser Aspekt ist aus psychologischer Sicht sehr wichtig, genauso wie die Frage, wie die App überhaupt mit den Userinnen und Usern kommuniziert.
So, wo stehen wir jetzt also?
Noch immer sehr vieles unklar, aber es gibt eine grobe Richtung.
Was aber immer klarer wird: Die App kann nur ein Baustein sein.
Sehr viel wichtiger bleiben wahrscheinlich zunächst:
Abstand halten. Wenige soziale Kontakte, Hygieneregeln einhalten, Masken, und ein Verbot von Großveranstaltungen.
Die App sollte eigentlich schon seit Ostern da sein, da kam aber erst mal eine ganz andere App, nämlich die Datenspende-App
für Fitness Tracker und Smartwatches des RKI.
Und jetzt möchte Gesundheitsminister Spahn auch noch eine Quarantäne App.
Das heißt: Eine freiwillige App, bei der man überprüfen kann,
ob sich die Leute an die Quarantäne und die damit verbunden Auflagen halten.
Durch das Hin und Her und das Kommunikationschaos der Bundesregierung geht wertvolle Zeit und Vertrauen verloren.
Für die Tracing App an sich, bleibt aber die Frage: „Wann kommt sie denn jetzt?“
Wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass Apple und Google uns das für Mitte, Ende Mai versprochen haben, könnte ich mir vorstellen,
dass die Zeit bis dahin jetzt schon zur Entwicklung genutzt wird, dann treten noch ein paar Unwägbarkeiten auf
und ich denke, wenn jetzt kompetent gearbeitet wird, sollte Juni für so eine App ein Launchdatum sein.
Es wird also noch Wochen oder Monate dauern.
Contact Tracing über eine App kann ein Baustein sein, um weiter zu einer Lockerung zu kommen,
aber ich fürchte, es ist nicht der heilige Gral.
Wir müssen uns einfach mit dem Gedanken anfreunden, dass es keine Wunderwaffe gegen die Pandemie gibt.
Auch eine App ist leider keine.
Und bis man wirklich nachvollziehen kann, was die App denn jetzt genau bringt, werden vermutlich Monate vergehen.
Also für eine schnelle Lockerung und ein:
„Wir laden uns alle die App herunter und dann geht es zurück in die Normalität.“
- Dafür wird die Tracing App erst einmal überhaupt nichts nützen.
Ich hoffe, ich konnte ein wenig Klarheit einbringen in die ganze Diskussion um die Corona Apps.
Wenn Ihr nichts mehr verpassen wollt,
ringsum Corona, gibt es hier oben eine Playlist des „ZDF Heute“-Nachrichtenkanals mit allen aktuellen Informationen
und hier unten findet Ihr die Playlist mit weiteren Videos von „ZoomIn“.
Ich freue mich, wenn ihr vorbeischaut.